-Lenny, oh!
-What's happening, man?
What's happening?
Good to see you.
-You look good, buddy.
-You look great.
-Thank you, pal.
Before we get into the book,
which I love,
I have a thousand questions.
Halloween is almost upon us
and I've already --
we've already gotten pictures
that people sent
of kids dressing up
as you for Halloween.
It's a very popular costume.
Do you know that?
-I've seen it.
I've seen it.
-This one here, though,
is my favorite.
Look at this one.
[ Laughter ].
-He got the plastic bag,
so he got it all.
-He's got the bodega bag, yeah.
I just love it.
I thought that was so funny
and so cute.
I want to talk about your book,
"Let Love Rule."
It documents the first
25 years of your life.
You do some of the fun stories,
but also some
hard-hitting stories.
Was it therapeutic for you
to write this?
-Extremely, and I found that,
while I was writing this book,
I was healed of so many
things in my past,
especially when it comes
to the relationship
between myself and my father.
We had a very -- we had a very
challenging relationship.
Although we loved
each other very much,
but we, you know,
we had our challenges.
And, in writing the book,
I was able to step back
and see people, and my father,
like characters.
And I was able to really
have a clear look
at my father for the first time
and I saw him as a man
just trying to get
through this life experience
with what he had
and it was --
it was really healing
and I fell in love
with my father all over again
through writing this book.
-You're very humble
in this book.
Because, when you just look
at it, you go,
"Dude, it's Lenny Kravitz.
You're an icon."
You're a stud, you're talented,
you can play, you can write.
But in this, you go like
you're growing up and you
have different phases
of singing
and who you want to be.
But then you're like,
"Oh, I love Prince.
I love David Bowie
-Mm-hmm.
-and, you know, Dylan."
And then, you end up touring
with a lot of these people.
-Yeah. My very first tour
was Tom petty.
He took me on an American
tour, playing arenas.
And then, Bob Dylan
took me on tour.
And then, David Bowie.
Yeah, I opened for David Bowie
at Dodger Stadium.
-Oh, my God.
-This is all during
my first album.
It was magical.
-Wow!
What do you remember?
I mean, last time, I think,
you were on our show,
you brought a harmonica
that was Bob Dylan's harmonica
and you let me play it,
which was --
I'll never forget.
-That's right.
That's right.
-I'll never forget it, buddy.
What was Bob like when you
played with Bob Dylan?
-Bob was great, man, you know.
He had an interest in me,
you know.
We played at a festival together
somewhere in Europe
when we first met
and he kept telling people,
I want to meet
that Black Jewish kid."
-[ Laughs ]
-So he came --
Actually, I went
to his dressing room
and he invites me to go on this
tour and it was amazing and --
Except, one night,
he called me to come out
to do "Maggie's Farm."
And he's like,
"Come out. Come out."
And I didn't know the words.
Like, you know,
I know some of the words,
but I didn't know the words...
-Yeah.
-...so I kind of mumbled
-through it,
which I guess, kind of,
is the gig anyway, right?
So.
-And it's Bob Dylan, so you
probably were going like,
"This is crazy.
I'm jamming with Bob
on 'Maggie's Farm.'"
That's the one he wanted you
out there for.
-That's the one.
That's the one.
-I love the book.
Again,
who did you think
this book is for?
-I think, you know, the thing
that I've been hearing a lot of,
which I'm happy about is,
you know, it shows people that
you really have to find
your lane, your destiny,
and to also stick to your dreams
and to your thought process
of how you think you should be.
You know, I was offered so many
record deals and opportunities
and there were a lot
of open doors to me,
but, just because you have
open doors in your life
doesn't mean that you have
to walk through them, you know.
Some are just to look into.
-Yeah.
-And, you know, for me,
it wasn't about money or fame.
I turned down many deals,
as you --
as you can read in the book,
because they wanted to change
my vibe, my expression,
my whole thing,
and I waited until
I actually found my sound
and was able to, you know,
sign with a label
who was willing to allow me that
and to allow me to develop.
-That must be so hard --
-So, you know, it's all about --
it's all about that journey
of finding your voice,
whatever that means,
in whatever field in your life.
-The book is called
"Let Love Rule."
It's available now.
Everyone, pick it up.
It's fantastic.
Lenny Kravitz,
we love you, buddy.
Come back whenever,
whenever, whenever.
Hopefully,
I get to see you in person.
-I love you, Jim.
Take care, man.
-I love you.